I ended the day looking like this
but I'm only telling you that cause
Jump scare
for the entirety of this video
I look like absolute shit
but we're heading out later
which means that my in laws are currently on their way
cause bless them
they kindly volunteered to babysit
and I wanna get the pins out later
so I'm marinating in fake tan and it's
a different brand to my usual
and I'll tell you
the developer is intense
and I have such a
small window to sort this house out
but I work well under pressure
and nothing will motivate me quite like the
threat of people coming over
my husband always teases me cleaning like
this whenever we need to go out
he doesn't see the point because I don't get to enjoy it
and it'll probably be messy by the time we get back
but I think that
“setting the vibes” needs to be formally recognised
as an official love language
because I know exactly what needs to be
done to this house to make it feel good
and if it feels good when my in laws walk in
then they'll feel good and if they feel good
here while they're babysitting
then maybe they wanna come back and do it again
do you see where I'm going with this
and also even though we've been married
coming up to 13 years
horrific I know
I still want them to think that their boy is in good hands okay
although I do believe that they've discovered my TikTok now
so they probably already know that I'm actually insane
but my final
and probably most compelling argument to
cleaning before you go out is
you do not wanna wake up dusty, in a filthy house
anyway you know how we’re heavily focused
on our pool renovation at the moment
every minute of sunshine we get we're spending outside
but the weather where I live is about as Moody as I am
we honestly get four seasons in one day
but today we're just getting one season
and it's the rainy season
so it's actually the perfect time to clean my house
I kinda due an inside day cause I've been
working my fkn ass off out there
and just kind of ignoring everything else that goes on inside
including the washing
which is been really piling up and took me a significant amount of time
but we're just gonna chuck Netflix on and power through it
And this… I'm kind of embarrassed about this
but I tell you what
my beautiful little girl is definitely the messiest of all of us
I can just about guarantee you when I wake up tomorrow
those toys will be everywhere again
But it's okay cause I tried my best and for at
least one moment it was clean
I do need to renovate that room
but not right now
right now I need to renovate myself
and head to coldplay